compound interest formula as this just
warms up what is the compound interest
formula so I would say for me it start
to the name principal pay for principal
times 1 1 plus usually hiring young ^
okay and some of them can be lowercase
it doesn't get done okay now just
quickly let's remember what's going on
you've got an amount that your your sum
of money is growing - okay you've got
the principal which is how much you
start with you've got a rate an interest
rate and then you've got an amount of
time that you're putting your investment
your money in the bank for right now
just don't under second right remember
when we started logs we said we'll all
go all about asking this question
something's growing and it's growing for
some amount of time okay now if all
you're interested in is I know how long
it's going to grow for I just want to
know how much I get at the end you don't
need marks you don't need that to ask
that question Exponential's will be fine
okay for instance I could say if I have
$100 and it's growing it I don't know
eight percent interest and I'm gonna
grow it for ten years
okay I know how to do exponential so I'm
just gonna plug that into my calculator
and off I go and I'll get an answer at
the end but logarithms about turning it
feeds around right about asking a
different question if I want to know is
that off I've got this amount of money
and I've got this amount of interest in
this amount of time if I don't know what
the time is right that's the question
that vlogs are asking how long did it
take your thing in your growing box to
get to such and such a science well it's
just the difference is that garden box
is a bank account that's the only
difference
that's what bank accounts are actually
Road boxes at least you took they are
okay so let's have a look at this
particular question number five let me
make a bigger for you so you can
actually read it
okay there might be some things now have
a look with me as is often the case
because this is like this is a real-life
situation so then they just hand you an
equation you have to read this carefully
interpret and fit into the equation you
already know read with me I'll determine
the number of years to the nearest year
so again you're asking about this line
okay that's what they want to know the
terminal number is it will take an
investment of $1000
pause investment of $1000 if you're
investing $1000 where does that belong
in this formula that's the principle is
it so I'm just gonna write that down
straight away okay to grow to $2,000
right mm where's that gonna go that's
the event that's how you're gonna that's
where you gonna end up right if it is
compound interest at a rate of 6%
forever
where do I stick that gonna that should
be the rate and because it's a
percentage I want to write it here as a
decimal right so I'm gonna write that as
1 plus 0.06 and then this gap here is
the one I want to solve it okay yeah I
can simplify this a little bit but I've
just evaluated the information the
question here my formula right what
kinds of things can I do to simplify
this before it to the right good I can
divide both sides by a thousand okay so
you can follow along with me I can say
two over there 1 plus 0.06 I don't need
to write that as two numbers that's just
1.06 to the power of n okay now this is
an exponential equation right it's got
an index so how do I rewrite it as a log
equation
I'll give you could start with an N
right N equals now when I'm converting
ya the base turns into the base right
base to base so that's the base there so
it will become the base here you see
that okay and then I've only got one
number left over so that you just things
in there okay now before we evaluate
this thing and use our
okay um remember what mugs me remember
when I kept on talking about my reader
Rory machine right this means tell me
how long it will take
if my growing machine grows at the red
1.06 until what until it's double the
size when you started right that's
Donald sighs your son you see how this
is exactly the metaphor that you need
because that's exactly what bank
accounts - okay now this point
remember we said ah why do we do this is
because sometimes you get you know
looking bases that are hard to work
well 1.06 is over we don't working base
right so I'm gonna use my change of base
law and I'm simply going to evaluate it
right I can say according to the change
of base ball and you look at here I've
got the base here and I've got the thing
is growing to here an easy way to
remember is you've got the numbers and
they're literally like above and below
each other he's the man one and he's the
high one and so the lower one becomes
the lower one and the high one becomes
the high one right so really simply I'm
gonna write this as log 2 on log 1.06
okay there's the change of base ball and
that I can sneak into my calculator
right can someone put in for me
it doesn't matter
remember cuz I can choose any face I
like so I'll still get whichever
whichever button you pressed if I put
the ll 2 and then what put a six still
get sent on one at least we should okay
now does that answer the question what
was the question
determine the number of years to the
nearest year to the nearest year now
clearly it looks like twelve years we
kind of got lucky
we kind of got lucky because eleven
point eight nine obviously rounds up
okay
just suppose play make-believe with me
for a second so please it wasn't eleven
put it on suppose one point one nine
okay now this rounds down doesn't it so
you'd usually say oh I guess that means
11 years okay just one little problem
okay this is the subtle difference
between just doing pure mathematics at
the moon of nowhere and hey I'm actually
trying to make some money right if I say
eleven
I say eleven I don't need to guess how
much money I've got in my account I have
a compound interest formula right I can
work it out so in fact I know it's gonna
be a thousand dollars it's what I
started with x 1.06 that's what's
happening with the interest in the
growth to the power of 11
off you go crunch it out you get a
number with some weak decimal after it
okay can someone quickly tell me what it
is I can tell you it's out to the one
okay hey wait what happened I was trying
to grow to 2 grand and I clearly didn't
get there why not
obviously didn't get to ground because I
rounded this down so this is also gonna
go down right so in this question and if
they're crafted well for you you should
be fine you can see you just round and
no big deal okay but if I want to get to
a certain amount of money in a real way
you know what you're gonna round up no
matter what okay because if I want to
get to at least two thousand dollars
then I need to go past this point not
reversed in time because at that point I
won't actually have
two grand okay so do you see like think
about the question you'll answer it
right and don't just round because I
know how to round think about why you're
rounding and what effect rounding down
around it up has okay okay now you can
see how I used to change a baseball here
but remember I said to you don't to know
the change of baseball how would I solve
this question and I'll give you a clue
we go from here how would I solve this
question without the change in baseball
see if you can remember back to this
question you can still do it very good
taking logs of both sides this step
that's what really made the change of
baseball work okay that's how we solved
this question in the first place okay so
really quick can you know how to write
this down but if I am taking onto both
sides I'm going to get log 2 equals log
of this thing right what do I do with
that what can I do I can move the power
at the front right that's going to
become n log 1.06 over there and the
Lord to is to hang up and then just to
get n I divided which is exactly what
right which is exactly what the change
of baseball told me just slightly
quicker okay so if you forget your
change of baseball no big deal okay
you can still see I get there in fact
there's my line which is exactly the
same as that okay but this just sort of
quickens it a little bit and you'll need
to learn eventually anyway okay yes
you mean when you're going from here to
here yeah that is absolutely a common
error okay
now by the way just in case that
happened let's just imagine this right
at this point groups I I do it backwards
okay
now what this meat is me when I put this
in I'm gonna get a number out on time
let's just have a look at what number I
get I'm gonna get it strikes out 106
okay now excuse me the number I'm
getting is 0.08 for that 0.08 for now at
this point and I try and mention as much
as I possibly can okay you are always
doing a common-sense check I'm always
doing it wherever you can apply common
sense to the question okay now what this
is saying is oh yeah
after like this is only years right this
is like point zero eight of a year is
like one month thereabouts
okay um after one month my money has
magically doubled
that's pretty impressive all wrong okay
so then you think okay something has
gone wrong and then you pedal back pedal
back until you identify where the error
could possibly have been and then you
see oh no I've done things upside down
okay and in some ways like you know this
is just algebra
it's just rearranging things and it's
just the logs being there makes things a
little bit harder to see but you can
identify the error easily enough okay